حزمه المساعدات الامريكيه العسكريه
المقبله لاوكرانيا وحديث وزير الدفاع
الايطالي لما سبقهما من اعلان عده دول
عزمها تزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات كلها عوامل
تظهر ما يمكن وصفه بالتحول في نوعيه
السلاح وفعاليه فكيف كانت قد تسلمت في وقت
سابق منظومه صاروخيه من طراز هاي مارس
الامريكيه وام ار ال ار اس
270 البريطانيه التي يصل مدى الواحده
منهما الى نحو ثمانين كيلومترا لكن حزمه
المساعده العسكريه المقبله ستتضمن صواريخ
بعيده المدى لم تحدد نوعيتها بعد او مداها
وفي الحديث عن الدبابات فان اوكرانيا كانت
قد تسلمت مثلا دبابات المانيه مضاده
للطائرات من طراز جبارد وجرى ايضا الحديث
عن تسليمها عربات براد الامريكيه المدرعه
لكن وقبل ايام اعلنت دول عديده انها
ستسلمك دبابات قتاليه متطوره ابرامز
الامريكيه وليبارد الالمانيه ولوكلير
الفرنسيه وتشالنجر البريطانيه وبيتي 91
الهولنديه كذلك تسلم اوكرانيا منظومات
دفاع جوي مثل ايرس تي اس ال الالمانيه
وسبيدا الايطاليه وكروتانا الفرنسيه
ويتراو مداها بين 20 و40 كم لكن القوه
الاوكرانيه ستزود به منظومه الامريكيه
التي يصل مداها الى نحو 160 كيلومترا
وايضا سانتي الايطاليه الفرنسيه القادره
على اعتراض عشرات الصواريخ البالستيه
والصواريخ روز وطائرات المقاتله وتدمير 10
منها في وقت واحد
مدير مكتبه الجزيره
كما ينضم الينا من واشنطن مراسل الجزيره
محمد الاحمد زور ابدا معك وكيف تنظر روسيا
لهذا الكم من الاسلحه التي بات يتدفق او
توعد به اوكرانيا في هذه الحرب
نفس الاسطوانه التي بداتها منذ ان اعلن
الغرب عن تزويدي اوكرانيا او امكانيه
التجويد اوكرانيا بدبابات وبسلحه هجوميه
والمواقف الروسيه تاتي في نفس السياق
بمعنى ان هذه الاسلحه الجديده التي ستمد
بها همم الدول الغربيه اوكرانيا ستؤدي
بالدرجه الاولى الى تطوير التصعيد الى
الانتقال المواجهه بشكل او باخر الى
مواجهه شبه مباشره بين روسيا وحلف شمال
الاطلسي وان هذا الامر لا يعني باي حال من
الاحوال لان المسائل الغربيه
ستحقق نتائجها براي ال همم الثالثه رؤوس
وهذا التصريح على سبيل المثال كان من رئيس
الجهاز الاستخبارات الخارجيه الشرقيه
الاحلام الغربيه
همم تحقيق النصر استراتيجي على روسيا لن
تتحقق وان كل الدبابات وكل الاسلحه التي
ستصل الى اوكرا الى اوكرانيا ستلقى نصير
تلك الاسلحه همم الاخرى التي حصلت عليها
اوكرانيا في وقت سابق بمعنى انا سيد- انه
سيتم تدميرها هو حرقها على لسان همم اساس
الروس وبالتالي الموقف الروسي سياتي في
سياقه كما ذكر وبالتالي لا نتوقع ان يكون
هناك همم على الاقل في المعنى السياسي
مواقف اخرى بانتظار وصول تلك الاسلحه الى
اوكرانا ان وصلت بالفعل وكيف روسيا ستعامل
معها فعليا على الارض فعليا اوكرانيا
ستكون هي المحاكم الارض الاوكرانيه العرض
الموحله التي تعرفها الحرب العالميه
الثانيه بشكل جيد ستكون ليس فقط لقدره
روسيا على مواجهتها اسلحه الانترنت وايضا
لقدره اسلحه نيته على ان تكون فعاله في
تلك الاجواء وفي تلك الاراضي همم
اضافه لنا ربما ستكون اول مواجهه مباشره
بين همم بعض الحرب العالميه الثانيه بين
جيش غربي بين جيش اوروبي وجيش روسي على
اراضي كانت في الفضاء السوفيتي السابق وما
تزعل على الاقل بالمفهوم الروسي جزء من
الفضاء الروسي الجيو الاستراتي محمد
الاحمد يبدو ان ما كان ممنوعا في بدايه
هذه الحرب وفتره معينه منها فتى الان
مسموحه على مستوى الاسلحه النوعيه التي
تقدم الى اوكرانيا خاصه من جانب الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هل تضع الولايات
المتحده سقفا معينه خطا احمر لا يمكن
تجاوزه فيما يتعلق بما يقدم عسكريه
لاوكرانيا
ربما واحد من الخطوط الحمراء في ما يتعلق
بالمساعدات الامريكيه لاوكرانيا خطها
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن عند الناس سئل
عن مساله تقديم مقاتلات الاف 16 لاوكرانيا
اجاب
بالقطعه بانه بان هذا الخيار ليس واردا
على الاقل في هذه المرحله تقديم مقاتلات
امريكيه من طراز اف 16 لان ذلك سياخذ بكل
تاكيد الحرب في اوكرانيا الى مستوى اخر
تماما وبالتالي ربما يقرا ذلك على انه
واحد من الخطوط الحمر همم الامريكيه على
الرغم من ان المواقف الامريكيه تبدلت
مرارا بشان تقديم مساعدات عسكريه الى
اوكرانيا منذ بدا هذه الحرب وراينا في
الاونه الاخيره كيف تتجاوزت الولايات
المتحده والحلفاء الغربيون الخلافات بشان
تقديم همم دبابات قتاليه للمره الاولى الى
اوك لو بالتالي هناك تحفظ نعم ولكن جميع
الخيارات مطروحه على الطاوله باعتبارا
للولايات المتحده تعتبر ان تقديم
المساعدات الى اوكرانيا ياخذ بعين
الاعتبار المتقلبات الاوكرانيه وايضا
الواقع الميداني مع استمرار القتال لكن
بالنسبه للمساعدات او حزمه المساعدات
العسكريه الجديده التي يتم الحديث عنها
والتي اشارت اليها وكاله رويترز في
الحقيقه هناك بعض الضبابيه بشان هذه
المساعده مياده اولا لم يتم الاعلان عنها
بشكل رسمي يتوقع ان يتم الاعلان عنها في
وقت لاحق من هذا الاسبوع لكن تقريبا وكاله
رويترز نقل عن مسؤولين امريكيين ان هذه
الحزمه قد تبلغ قيمتها حوالي همم 200
مليون دولار قد تشمل صواريخ بعيده المدى
للمره الاولى لكن بعض التقارير الامريكيه
كقرير لوكاله بلومبي يتحدث عن الامر يتعلق
بمدفعيه وذخائر بعيده وليس صواريخ بعيده
المدى وبالتالي هناك دعوه للانتظار لغايه
الانتهاء من تفاصيل هذه الحزمه التي اشارت
وكاله رويترز الى انه قد يتم الاعلان عنها
في وقت لاحق من هذا الاسبوع لكن من الان
وحتى ذلك الوقت هناك تحذير بان هذه
العمليه متغيره وقد تشمل بطبيعه الحال
تغييرات قبل ان تمر الى مكتب الرئيس بايدن
والتوقيع عليها والاعلان عنها بشكل رسمي
لكن بكل تاكيد اي مساعدات امريكيه متطوره
سواء ذخائر او صواريخ بعيده المدرسه
ستساعد اوكرانيا بكل تاكيد في استهداف
العمق الروسي بما قد يشمل شبه جزيره القرم
باعتبارها يعني منطقه استراتيجيه اساسيه
في اي عمليه عسكريه تقول الكثير من
المصادر ان روسيا تستعد لشنها في الرابع
المقبل مياده شكرا محمد الاحمد مراسل
الجزيره من واشنطن وشكر موصول لك من موسكو
مدير مكتب الجزيره زور شوش